en ce vendredi 10 mai pleine période de
vacances scolaires ce jeune homme ne se
balade pas paul a choisi une autre
option celle des révisions un mois du
baccalauréat il suit un stage intensif
de physique-chimie un stage organisé par
l'association de soutien scolaire
archimède avec deux heures de cours tous
les matins pendant une semaine
paul peut oublier les grasses matinées
s'en donnent un peu tout ce qu'on
apprend pour ses vacances
ses parents n'ont pas eu besoin
d'insister à 17 ans parle s'est inscrit
à ce stage de sa propre initiative
disons qu'il est réaliste j'ai un peu de
difficulté en physique chimie notamment
mon bac blanc qui s'est pas très bien
passé pas très bien passé c'est à dire
j'ai eu 4 pas de quoi le démotiver dans
son établissement le lycée saint
françois d'assise de montigny le
bretonneux 100 % des élèves ont le bac
l'année dernière aucune raison donc que
veulent ne fasse exception
on a plusieurs et s'élève de différent
ici ici et ça nous permet de voir les
différences entre les lycées vols sont
les mieux préparés moins bien préparés
et comme chacun avance à son rythme les
cinq élèves définissent eux-mêmes leur
objectif du jour
chaque élève a des méthodes différentes
à des problèmes mission donc le but
c'est justement c'est de combler ses
problèmes de chacun fait donc c'est
vraiment un enseignement adapté à chaque
élève
aujourd'hui paul s'entraîne sur un sujet
type bac conforme au tout nouveau
programme a lancé cette année j'ai
travaillé ça chez moi pendant ces deux
jours et je suis en train de le faire
corriger par le prof est le finir sur
ses conseils
ici on nous explique beaucoup plus pour
beaucoup plus le temps de nous expliquer
vous comprends
comprend plus vite plus vite la france
mais qui n'est pas le cas pas mal de
connaissances ont ce qu'on peut lui
apporter au final c'est un créneau de
deux heures ou lorsqu'il est bloqué sur
un exercice non le des blocs au lieu
qu'ils passent une heure à la maison à
se bloquer dessus on joue en cinq
minutes on débloque et après les repas
et le professeur a visé juste pas ce qui
est bien ici c'est que on a un cadre de
travail beaucoup plus calme beaucoup
plus une ambiance de travail qui je
pense beaucoup mieux qu'à la maison
c'est sûr on a besoin de concentration
pour travailler ce que je dis absolument
pas chez moi et ça me permet de mieux me
concentrer pour me prendre mais aussi à
les placer au travail maintenant on
retrouve pas le dans deux semaines chez
lui cette fois